hello everybody hope they are good first
of all I want to say thank you to all of
you for watching the video supporting
the content and the truth is that you
know since I started to PL the daily
videos back that was two weeks ago I've
been nailing the charts um I mean this
was yesterday's projection check this
out okay Wick fill strategy that by the
way I don't know if I would have notice
about this week without the indicator
because it's a bit hidden but my
indicator told me yep that's a week all
I said all right let's trade then H we
held a support there then sweep off the
highs because as you can see that was a
clear resistance you have here one two
three times that price got rejected
there so any Trader trading this Z going
short is going to be placing the stop
losses above this area okay that's what
we said this here is a stop loss Zone
okay pretty much the same as the day
before same setup and it happened too
okay so then sweep of the highs reverse
price back down down and test this
support and here I was telling you it's
very likely that we see another sweep of
the lows and it happened check this out
okay what happened sweep of the lows hit
the stop losses from any any Trader long
in this this setup here okay and then
you have there the bounds and then we
broke down again but uh very good trade
yesterday again and I've been thinking
overnight and I think that YouTube is
helping myself it's making me even a
better analyst a better Trader um
perhaps is because I'm putting a lot
more effort than because you know of
course the videos are not Financial
advice I always tell you that it's been
a description a disclaimer but I have
the responsibility to to lead you well
okay to guide my followers well I I
don't want to mislead anybody so I have
to check everything in the chart and in
the liquidations heat maps in the ear
book very carefully to come with an with
a projection okay with a setup that it's
a high probability to trade so yeah I
think the extra pressure that comes from
YouTube is helping me okay that's a
little um reflection that that I did
last night so I wanted to share it with
you now we're going to talk about
Bitcoin okay what is going on here let
me remove all of this mess okay I'm
going to keep that resistance on also um
a couple of these ago posted on Twitter
next uh I was expecting um some kind of
a range because guys go to the 4our time
frame what is this madness Okay okay
look at that yes we we were in a Range
here okay this was a range here okay and
that was quite boring to be honest but
but look what happened since since
literally Tuesday well when Thursday it
was Thursday really literally one week
ago one week and one day ago all of this
massive leg up it's insane okay in
literally 8 days we went up
22% that's mad okay so yes of course you
know nothing goes up forever right and
it's normal to see this kind of
consolidations before the next leg up
okay and perhaps it's time to have a
longer consolidation and maybe 52,000 is
the level we see that okay that's what
I'm trying to say maybe we see some more
consolidation in this area for a while
okay maybe something like this and then
well we'll start to take liquidity from
both ends I don't know if we go up or
down but and check the weekly chart for
that right but yeah maybe it's time to
see some more consolidation that's the
that's the first thing that I wanted to
say now if we go into the one or time
frame we can see that this is you know
this is pretty much a range a range is
forming here okay this is some kind of a
range you can see how we did a sweep of
the highs to take up that liquidity we
haven't really swept the lows yet uh so
who knows maybe next week we come um
again to this area to take this
liquidity okay but a range is forming
and now we have the weekend in during
the weekend there is usually not much
liquidity volatility it's a lot less so
it's likely that we stay in this range
okay consolidating that's quite likely
now I don't think we're going to go of
course to the cuz look if this was the
range let me Mark it like this for you
all right so this is basically then the
middle of the
range all right let me change the color
I'm not expecting Bitcoin over the
weekend to go below this yellow box cuz
I'm expecting consolidation over the
weekend in the top half of the range
okay so yeah maybe we have consolidation
like this that's what I'm trying to say
I don't think we're going to go over the
weekend this low here okay now of course
there is a chance today is still uh
Friday and we have the whole New York
session ahead of us so yes why not why
couldn't we see some more upside that
can happen Okay and we're going to go to
the weekly time frame this is what I've
been doing in the last few videos
because there is a level here that I
find quite interesting because it's
basically a trigger for the next move
and it's this resistance here all right
that resistance there I mean it's insane
look at that you can see how we're
literally testing the top of the
resistance right that is the basically
die Spike there because we've seen here
a a few sell offs from this level okay
yeah here you have a sell off here you
have a sell off is it going to happen
again for this to not happen this
potential resistance and and this
rejection back to this area here to
42k it can happen Okay and the only way
to validate this scenario at least in my
opinion is if we start to see
consolidation above the resistance okay
because that's going to tell me that y
we're going to see a move up to 60k
because we've been talking about this
resistance all week that would be be the
next resistance to the upside okay that
level over there I want that to be clear
so the quickly candle is very important
to me I want to see at least two weekly
candles closing above these orange books
for me to think okay yeah that was not a
sweep of the highs it's likely to see
consolidation so we still have a couple
of days to this Friday basically the
last minute of this Candlestick is on
Sunday at 11:59 p.m. 1 minute to to
12:00 to midnight and is still a chance
of course that we see a move higher
close the weekly candle Above This
resistance then you know next week I
would like to see another candes closing
above that resistance and that's is
going to tell me 60k is coming baby
but but until that doesn't happen the
most likely scenario to me is going to
be rejection at that resistance sell off
back to this level around 43k okay
because yes that's this this area here
could act as support okay that's
actually at
43,700 all right then of course if you
lose the level you fall back inside this
range and that's going to take you to
41,000 so as long as we don't close
weekly
candlesticks again I want to see at
least two weekly candlesticks closing
Above The Orange Box as long as that
doesn't happen I'm not want to favor 60k
and I'm going to favor rejection drop
here I want that to be very clear so
keep an eye on this weekly Candlestick
on this resistance over the weekend you
can Mar in your chart it's exactly
53,000 okay I want to see Bitcoin
closing above
53,000 a midnight on Sunday all right um
and to be we're not that far away so why
not what couldn't that happen Okay uh
we're only $600 away so um keep an eye
on that now the truth is that Fridays
are quite tricky to trade and some
Fridays at least in my experience is
better to step away and to not trade and
if you look at the price action that
we're having in front of
us I don't really see any clear trade
okay that's the truth I don't see a real
trade for Bitcoin but I'm already
thinking for potential trades over the
weekend and most of you guys that that
follow me you know that I don't like
trading Bitcoin at the week I don't
touch Bitcoin at the weekend okay but
altcoins can be a good option and we
have to see that rotation from Bitcoin
to altcoins is it happening well check
out Bitcoin okay Bitcoin is
consolidating it's not going down is it
it's consolidating this is sideways move
since pretty much
um since yesterday okay yesterday
started that consolidation but on
Wednesday we pumped okay Wednesday we
went higher
Thursday
consolidation go to the Bitcoin
dominance let's see what the Bitcoin
dominance is doing look at that guys all
right Wednesday what is Wednesday
Wednesday
consolidation yesterday we
dropped okay so basically you're telling
me that on
Wednesday the Bitcoin dominance was
consolidating Bitcoin was going up and
then on Thursday
the Bitcoin dominance is going down
while Bitcoin is consolidating okay can
you see the Divergence what that is
telling me is that money is moving
between Bitcoins to
altcoins not between sorry from Bitcoin
to altcoins all right and that can lead
to good opportunities over the weekend
for altcoins that's what I'm paying
attention to this is the mindset that I
have okay go to
Solana this is Solana okay I just uh
added the 50ma in the for time frame
well this liquidity pool is fully taken
all right uh that was our entry back at
the time but um what gets my
attention is that if Bitcoin well if
money is moving between from from
Bitcoin to altcoins what's going to
happen this weekend when Bitcoin is
going to be consolidating and the
Bitcoin
dominance I doubt it goes up while
Bitcoin consolidates because it's going
down or well it's consolidating when
Bitcoin goes up and it's going down when
Bitcoin consolidates so the Bitcoin
dominance is quite par in comparison to
bitcoin so if Bitcoin consolidates over
the weekend I don't think that the
Bitcoin dominance is going up because
that scenario would send altcoins lower
okay so that scenario I see very
unlikely and the scenario that I have in
front of me is altcoins going higher
okay so for that I need to try to find
some entries for altcoins now the first
entry that comes to my mind that it's
quite
uh can be used as a reference and it's
quite easy is the 4H hour 8 check this
out okay test a support price goes up if
we do another test a support and price
can continue going up okay so that's are
basically the setups that I'm looking at
go to chain link what's chain link doing
okay so chain Ling the same look at that
4H hour 50a tested a support then price
can continue going up is it going to
happen the same are we now in this stage
okay is this the same as this can chain
link go again to the 50 Ma and then we
can see higher prices that's what I'm
paying attention to okay ax go to ax let
me see the same exactly the same guys is
the 50 ma we also have a Weck here
reason to go back to that level okay
pretty much the same as happened here or
here okay we go back to fill the week is
it possible that retra that week while
the 50 is catching up he basically
matches the 100% of the week with the 50
ma tested a support then send prices
higher over the weekend all right
because yes we're talking here about uh
8% move yeah even 10% move that can
happen over the weekend guys and this
can continue go to our vitum for example
look at this okay well I guess this was
maybe in the daily no in the 1 hour time
frame uh let me check this out what have
I Mark here yep that massive liquidity
pull
you also have here the daily 50 ma that
if we change it I want to check this
what happened here y you also with the
daily 50 MAA and that liquidity pull
bounce area boom it happened it bounced
from there okay let's remove that let's
set again the 50 ma to the current chart
time frame there you go go to the 4 Hour
time
frame um what do we see we see the exact
same thing okay the 50 ma is there
actually with already happen we already
test the 50a and then you know price is
already going up uh 3% okay but yeah
keep an eye on it because maybe it
retested that level if it holds long
opportunity over the weekend okay how
much is this back to the highs another
8% yeah around 80% move these are the
moves I'm looking over the weekend guys
okay so um that's pretty much everything
I want to say today a bit of a high time
frame view uh for Bitcoin and what to
look for in the at the weekly at the
weekly close that I think it's a very
important time frame the weekly time
frame so now you guys know what I'm
looking at in that Weekly Candlestick on
Sunday and I don't see any high
probability trade for Bitcoin today I
see quite choppy quite boring today
Fridays you have to be careful trading
on Fridays because they are quite trixy
and a few opportunities or at least what
I believe that can happen over the
weekend with alons okay I think that
there is an opportunity
that money keeps switching from Bitcoin
to alins over the weekend he's been
doing this for the past month pretty
much I've been I usually don't trade
over the weekend but this last 3 four
weeks it's been it's been great to trade
Al coin so uh I see the same happening
this weekend okay so uh keep an eye on
it it's study what I showed you go
through the Alin charts try to find some
setups and keep an eye on put some
alerts if you need to because I think
and uh maybe we can eat some popcorns
this weekend on the guys in the telegram
know what that means okay popcorns are
art coins so uh thank you so much for
watching guys and I'll see you
soon